ではよろしくお願いします
なんかいつでも簡単な経典説明しちゃってなんか不満があるでしょうということですね
まあこれもどちらかというと簡単ですけどね
難しい経典があるんだけど
私には説明できないんです
あの これは中部経典の最後の経典ですね
百五十二番目 えーと あの
インリレバーバナースッタという名前なんですね
インリレというのは あの
この六根のこと 眼耳鼻舌身意というね
目耳鼻舌体と心というね
六根のこと 六根 根というのは元ですね
根ということですね そこは根
元になって我々の概念
考え方がざーっと現れてくるんです
目からね 情報入ったら
まあ考えるは考える 耳から情報入ると
まあもうもう次から次へと考えるとかそうやって
我々のこの六根がありまして
六根から情報が入って
まあ考えたりするんですね
まあ一番まあ人間にとって問題っていうのは
この考えることなんですよ
肉体っていうのは別に問題ではありません
それも内なる人々は肉体のことばっかし
まあ気功やろうが 指圧やろうとかね
針をやろうとかね で 肉体のことはどうでもいいことなんですね
例えば指圧やっても針をやってもね
これ感覚ですよ 感覚によって
ああ 気分が良かったというだけで
肉体には何の変化もないんです
だから精神的に まあ生きるということはまあ心ですからね
だからまあ仏教はそういうところだけ考えているんですね
エワンメスタンエカンサメヤンバゲワカランカカンジェーカジャンガカジャンガラヤンリヘレティムケールワニ
あんまりなかなか出てこない場所なんですけどね
カジャンガラというところでムケールという森でいた
いた時 この経典の内容をお話しましたということなんです
なかなかあの どこかとわからないんですよ
アタコウタロマナオパラサリアンテーワーセ
イエナ
イエナバガワテーヌパサンカミパサンカミットバガワタサッビンサンモーディサンモーダニヤンカタンサーラーニーヤンエーティサーレットワエーカマンタンニシーディ
で出来事 ウッタロという名前の人
マナオっていうのは まあいくらか若い人に使う単語なんですね
ウッタル君みたいな感じで
この若い人はパーラーサリヤアンテーワーシ
パーラーサリヤという先生がいて
その先生の弟子なんです
この先生は誰でしょうかとはまあ経典ではわからないし
なかなか出てくる人物ではないんです
場所も全部 このウッタルという人はお釈迦様に会って
ウッタルさんはパーラーサリヤ先生の弟子ですね
だからパーラーサリヤ先生の弟子であるウッタルという人がお釈迦様に会って挨拶をして
礼をして まあ座りましたと
エーカマンタンニシンナンコウッタランマナワンパーラーサリヤンテーワシンバガワエータドフォーチェ
そこで座ってから このパーラ
ウッタルさんがお釈迦様にこういうことを言います
です バガワエータドフォーチェ
お釈迦様が言うんです
パーラーサリヤ ウッタルさんが座りました
座ったところで お釈迦様先にしゃべるんです
普通は順番逆なんですけど
来た人がお釈迦様に先に質問をするのは普通なんですけど
この場合はお釈迦様先に話すのです
ウッターラさんに何か聞くのです
その場合はお釈迦様のをよく知っている人でないとなりたないし
あるいは結構若者でなければ成り立たないし
まあ二十歳ぐらいだったら
やっぱり年上の人が先に喋らないとね
デーセーティウッターラ・パーラーサリヨ・ブラームノ・サーヴァカーナン・インドリヤ・バーワナーンティ
と質問する お釈迦様がお釈迦様の質問はこういうこと
パーラーサリエバラモンがサーヴァカーナン
自分の弟子たちにインドリヤ・バーワナーということを教えていますか？と
経典の名前なんですね
インドリヤ・バーワナー
インドリヤっていうのは六根でしょ
バーワナーっていうのはメディテーションということなんですね
瞑想っていうことなんですね
それでメディテーションと言ったって全然意味がわからないし
瞑想と言ったっても全然意味がわからないでしょう
バーワナーっていうのは意味がある単語なんです
バーワナーっていうのは育てるということなんですね
一生懸命成長させる 育てる
あるいは増え増すとかね
増やすとかね しかし 金を増やすことにはバーワナーと言いません
バーワナーっていうのは
このなることによって成長する成長なんですね
ですから そこで成長できるのは心だけなんです
他何も成長できません
じゃあ我々何か植物でも成長させることはできますかね？できませんよ
植物は勝手に成長するんであって
できません 体のことにして体勝手に変化するんであって
私たちは何もできません
できると思ってるところはちょっと違いますよ
医者には病気治すことはできませんし
それは体が勝手に治してやるか
そのままにいるかということを体が勝手にやってます
植物と同じなんで 植物には水をあげることとかね
剪定してあげることとかはできますけど
成長するのはそちらの勝手です
しかし 心だけは手を加えて成長させることはできます
例えば ある木が実るまでは五年かかるといえば五年かかりますよ
いくらでももう強引にもう針金で引っ張っておいて
強引に伸ばしちゃってできません
しかし 百年生きたっても全く心は成長しないんですよ
心は成長させなくちゃあかんです
成長させようと思えば
まあ二十歳の人にもものすごい
すごい瞑想習慣で見事に心をもう完全なところまで成長させることができます
ですから バワナという単語は瞑想メディテーションということになって
心育てるということに使う単語になっています
そこで今日のポイントはインディババナという六根の瞑想なんですね
じゃあ六根って肉体だから
目耳鼻は肉体でしょう
肉体のヨーガ瞑想でしょうか
と では違います 目と言ったっても
もう肉体の目玉ではないんです
そちらで心が生まれるんですね
そういうところの瞑想なんです
それで答え この人のデセティボゴートマパパラサリヨブラクマンサワカーナンインディババナンテ
お釈迦様にね 名前で言いますけど
まあ作戦に言うんですね
もうデセティ教えてますよと
パーラサリバラモンが自分の弟子たちにインディババナを教えていますよと
それから単語をパーリ語で覚えてください
もうまた日本訳はしません
インディバハナという六根に対する成長の仕方とか瞑想ですね
実践 六根というのは六つのチャネルから心が生まれる
そこは育ててみるということなんです
それはインディバハナ
それでこのパーラサリバラモンが教えてるんだって
その方法は それでお釈迦様が次に聞くんです
ヤタカタンパナウットレデセティパーラサリヨブラクマンサワカーナンインディババナンテ
ヤタカタン それどういうふうなものでしょうかと
パーラサリバラモンが自分の弟子たちに教えるインディバハナっていうのはどういうものでしょうか？とお釈迦様は聞くんです
それでこのウットラさんが答えるんです
イダボーゴートマチャックナルーパンナパッサティソーテーナサッダンナスナーティ
エワンコボーゴートマデセティパーラサリヨブラクマンサワカーナンインディババナンテ
そこでゴートマさん こういう風に教えますよ
チャックナルーパンナパッサティ
目でいろいろ形を見ないこと
ソーテーナサッダンナスナーティ
耳であれこれやと音を聞かないでくれと
そうなると次は書いてないんです
これはまあいい加減に付け加えたか
わざわざもうエピソードがなくて困ってエピソードを付けたか
どちらかわからないんですけど
こんなにだらしない話もちょっと私は個人的には疑問に思いますけど
あの あるいはどうでもいいことだから省略しようかなと思った可能性もあります
何か出来事がないと経典
説法になりませんだから
そこでこのバラモンの教えは
この目でものを見ないこと
耳で音を聞かないこと
頑張ってくださいと それで立派になりますよということなんです
でお釈迦様は判断するんですね
エワンサンテコウットラアンドーバビティンディオバビッサティバヒバディロバビティンディオバビッサティ
エワンサンテ これこんなことだったら
ウットラ君 アンドー 目が見えない人はもう成長した人になるんだよと
バビティンディヤっていうのは心を育てた人
これ心育てるという項目
テーマなんです だから心育てるために
あのパーラスパスポートラーサリヤさんいうのは見ないことにしましょうと
だけど ものを見ると心が汚れるんだからね
育てるところじゃないんです
見ないことにしよう 聞かないことにしようよと
ただ お釈迦様 それだったら
目がもともと見えない人はもう完成者ではないかなと
だって目から全然汚れたことがないんだから
一度も 生まれてから それからバディロっていうのは耳が聴覚障害者ですね
全然耳が聞こえない人だったらもう人格完成者でしょ
だって音を聞いたことはないしね
で 次の文章で あのヤタパーラサリヤッサバラモンアッサワチャナン
このパーラサリヤバラモンの言葉から計算すると
人格完成者っていうのは目が見えないと耳が聞こえない人でしょうと
初めから でアンドーユッタチャックナルーパンナパッセディバディロソーテーナサッダンナスナーティ
なぜならば 目が見えない人は目で色は見ないし
耳が聞こえない人はもう音は聞いてないでしょう
エヴ
ァン・ウッティ・ウットロ・マナボ・パラサリアンテ・ヴァーシ・トゥンニ・ブーと・マンク・ブーと・パッタ・カンド・アドー・ムコ・パッジャヤント・アッパティバーノ・ニシーディ
そう言われたら このウッタラさんがトゥンニ・ブーと黙って
マンク・ブーと もう何も言えなくなっちゃって
パッタ・カンド 体を落として
アドー・ムコ 下を向いて
パッジャヤント なんかもうもうと言いながら
アッパティバーの頭混乱して何もわからなくなっちゃって
もういきなり厳しくお釈迦様反応しちゃったんだから
一言で消しちゃったんで
やっぱりアーサリ様はよく考えて教えたと思いますけどね
目でいろんなものを見ると心汚れるでしょうと
堕落するでしょうと 音で
耳で音を聞いて心が堕落しているでしょうと
だからそれやめなさいよということですけどね
だからどこかの言い方が悪いんですよ
なぜならば お釈迦様もだいたいは心汚れるものを見るなよと言ってますよ
戒律のセクションでは
例えばこの芸術やら具体的やら女が裸で遊んで踊っているところやらね
見るなよと 修行中の人々はそれを見ると心がもうおかしくなっちゃって
もう汚れちゃってね まあ減速したくなるかもしれませんし
瞑想ができなくなるかもしれませんし
ですから まあそれは見るなよと
だから戒律っていうのは
まあ一応修行始めた人々に大変大事な修行で
だからそういう汚い言葉やらね
品のない言葉やら意味のない話やらね
聞くなよと いうことをお釈迦様もおっしゃってはいることはいるんですけど
おそらくこの若者の言い方がちょっとまずかったかもしれませんね
そこでブッダの説法が入ります
アッ
パコ・バガワ・ウッタラ・パーラ・サリアンテ・ヴァーシン・トゥンニ・ブータン・マンク・ブータン・パッタク・カンダン・アドー・ムカン・パッジャヤンタン・アッパティバーナン・ビビットワ
お釈迦様がこのウッタラ君がね
なんか何も言えなくなっちゃって黙っているところを見て
アーヤス・マンタン・アーナンダン・アーマン・テーシー
アーナンダ長老を呼びました
ウッタラさんには喋れません
アーナンダさんと会話するんです
それも一つのお釈迦様の方法なんです
この子はもうすごく落ち込んじゃったんですね
もう恥ずかしいんですよ
もう顔を上げられません
それでまたまた喋りだしちゃうと
これ精神的に苦しいんですね
その人にとっては 元気よく
またもう開き直ってお釈迦様と対話することができなくなる
できないんですね それでお釈迦様はまあそう置いといて
アーナンダ長老とちょこちょこと話しているんです
それを話していると聞いていればいいんです
そうすると 何のことなく自分に関係ないんだからね
自分と喋っているわけでもないんだから
ずっと話を聞くことはできるんです
だからそれをすごい親切に
ものすごく明確に計算してやってる態度なんです
一旦何もしゃべれなくなった状態になったら
もうまたいじるということはしません
いじるとさらにさらに落ち込んじゃうんですね
では あなたが教えてあげましょうと言ったっても
聞く気持ちが出てこないんです
ということで アーナンダ長老に話すんです
アニ
ャタコアーナンダデーセーティパーリパーラサリヨブラフマノサーヴァカーナンインディリバワナアニャタチパナアリアッサヴィネーアヌッタラーインディリバワナホーティーティ
アーナンダスコン アーナンダ
パーラサリブラフマンが弟子たちに教えるインドリバワナは違うもの
アリアヴィネー 聖者の教えではというのはブッダの教えですね
この尊い教えアリアヴィネーというのはね
尊い仏教の世界ではアヌッタラーインドリバワナ
アヌッタラーっていうのは無上たる無上というのはこの上のないというね
いわゆる何でしたっけ
超越した ちゃんとレベル超えてますよと
超越したインドリバワナはまた違いますよと
パーラサリさんのインドリバワナと
この仏道に語られている超越した無上たるインドリバワナが違いますよと
だからインドリバワナの意味だけよく覚えておいてください
まあ面倒くさいんだからその単語出てきます
それでアーナンダさん
長老が エータッサバガワーカーローエータッサスガトーカーローヤンバガワーリアッサビネーアヌッタラーインドリバワナデーセーヤー
それでお釈迦様がね 私の教え方違いますけどと言ったら
それはある信号なんですね
信号っていうのは お釈迦様は今教えたい気持ちでいるんです
そうするとアーナンダさんが
じゃあお釈迦様 この際
この機会ですので教えてくださいと
今アヌッタラーインドリバワナ
無上たる超越したインドリバワナを教える時間ですと
機会ですと バカトースッタビクダレスサンティーチ
お釈迦様から教えてあげたら
ビクたちはその通りに覚えるでしょうと
それでお釈迦様は テーネーヤーナンダスナーイサドカンマニシカロヒバシッサニーティ
それではアーナンダ よく聞きなさい
よく覚え思い出し もう考えなさい
喋りますよと 喋り お話
説法始まるんです エーワンバンテーティコーアーヤスマアーナンドーガグートーカッチャッソーッスカッチャッソーシ
はい わかりましたと もう返事して
それでおバカはエタド
お釈迦様このように語ります
カタンパナーナンダアリアッサビネーアヌッタラーインドリバワナホーティ
カタン どのようなものでしょうか
アリアッサビネー 仏道においては
聖者の教えにおいては
アヌッタラ 超越したインドリバワナというのはどのようなものでしょうか
これ一応セットでいきますので
あの  第1番目のセットになります
イダアーナンダビクノチャックナールーパンディスワウッパジティマナータンウッパジティヤマナータンウッパジティマナーパマナータン
例えばではなくて ここでアーナンダ
ビクのビクビクたちにチャックナールーパンディスワ
目でいろんなものを形見たところでウッパジティ
生まれますよと マナーパン
マナーパンというのは心地よいというね
気に入る 心地よい気分が生まれますよと
ウッパジティヤマナータン
それは心地悪い気分も生まれますよと
ウッパジティマナーパマナータン
あるいは両方とも同時に
同時にでもないんだけど
まあバラバラにも まあどちらでもないものも生まれますよということで
ウッパジティ  もう これマナーパマナータンとつなげていますけど
まあおそらく心地よくでもなく
心地悪いでもないという意味の方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
はい そこまですごい簡単単純でしょ
我々にしたっての 目で物を見ると気持ちよくなったりするし
気持ち悪くなったりするし
まあバラバラでね 気持ちいいか悪いかわからないんだけど
そういうバラバラの複雑な状況にもなったりはする
そこで瞑想というか修行なんですね
タンチャコーサンカタンオーラーリカンパティッチェサムッパンナン
タンチャコーサンカタン
この生まれた心地よさ
心地よさがありますね
何か見て ああ 気持ちいいやと花見たらえらい心地よくなるでしょ
その気持ちよくなったことはサンカタン作られたもの出来上がったもの
本物じゃないんです サンカタンというのはサンカールの単語で出来上がったもの
合成したもの 作られたもの
本物じゃない 花を見たんだから気分が良くなったんであって
花を見なかったら別になんもないでしょ
だから気分が良くなった気持ちいい
我は幸せだということはどうったことない
一時的な瞬間で出来上がった幻覚じゃなくて
組み立てた合成したものなんです
あの気持ちよさは 大あり感っていうのは
それほど優れたものじゃない
荒いという大荒れ方の荒いということで品がないという
いや 卑しいというくらいのものなんです
卑しい品がない そんなにすごい高度な
大変恐縮した心地よさじゃなくて
すぐ品がないものなんだ
だって花見たら誰でも気持ちよくなるでしょうしね
人間ならね そんなすごいということじゃないんだと
パティッチサモッパンナン
これ因縁によって現れたんだと
本来の心のある心地よさじゃないんです
ただ因縁によって 花は一つの原因で
目は一つの原因で見る
見えるという認識が一つの原因で
その 3つを合わせたところで心地よいと
結果 すごいシンプルでしょ
ということで勝ち入れないんですよ
だから俗世間とは違うんです
仏教と 本当にシンプルなんですけど
しかしすごい教えが高度なんです
ただ目で花を見たらえらい気分が良くなったと
それにもう溺れてみんなひどい目に遭うでしょうに
何トンぐらい上の公園でゴミばっかり溜まるでしょうね
まあ品がないというと猿みたいでしょう
ずっと花が咲いて見たら気分が良くなっただけのに
そんなのは誰の気分も良くなりますけど
だからそこまでアホになるべきかと
服を脱いでね こういう上野公園なんかいい 2回
3回ぐらい行ったこと昔ありましたけどね
あれは行く場所じゃないと思ったんですよ
だから花の美しさよりもう 10倍ぐらい下の方のゴミの量なんですね
それで酔っ払ってだらしなく遊んだりかが
で歌ったりも だからまあ歌える上手な人もいることいるね
だからであっちこっちバラバラな歌ね
もうもう二メートルごとに歌ってるとね
何が美しいかと でもそれでも楽しい
楽しいと強引に楽しみを作るんですよ
だから仏道とは全く正反対なんで
仏道というのは その楽しみさも
もうそんなに品があるものでも
高尚なものでも何でもないんだ
単なる因果法則で生まれた楽しみでしょうと
合成したものでしょうと
だからアリアヴィネヤっていうのは
品のある聖者の道 ノーブルという
このいわゆる貴族っていう意味なんですね
アリアっていうのはね
まあ貴族のいわゆる生き方という単語だけなんですけど
すごい俗世間よりはものすごい品が高いという意味で使ってますね
聖なるという意味でも使ってます
だから聖なる世界はそこと違いますよと
エータンサンタンエータンパニータン
エータン これが安穏である平安である
エータンパニータン これがとても優れている
ヤリダン 何でしょうかというと
ウペッカーということ
だから心地よさが生まれても
ウペッカーということがとても品の高い安穏な気持ちであると
それが瞑想っていうことなんです
このウペッカーっていうのは
あの斜という漢字書きますけど
心の波を立てないで平安に保つ
心はクールな状態で保つ
ウペッカーと呼ぶんです
そこで花が見たら すぐパッと気持ちよくなっちゃうんですよ
すぐこれは作られたもので
あまり品のあるものじゃない
誰にでもできますからね
それで さっとあの気持ちをウペッカーに持ってくる
平安に持ってくる あの瞬間で
この場合は興奮しないで
波を立たないで 落ち着いて平安でいるぞということが修行であって
瞑想であります だからバラモンさんみたいに見るなよと上の子に行くなよと心汚れますよということじゃないんです
肉体に束縛はさせません
だって何が見えるかというとわからないんだからね
生きている上では 見るなよと言ったってね
なかなか実行できるわけじゃないんですね
隠れてるしかないんですね
そうなってくると そうすると
人間の束縛されちゃって自由がなくなるんですね
自由の道を教える場合はね
たとえ肉体さえでも束縛されちゃうと意味がないでしょ
だからお釈迦様がそこは見るなよということは使わない
その代わりに 目に何が入るかわからない
時々ものを見ると心地よささが生まれるは
こっち時心心地悪くなるわ
時々バラバラ状態にもなるわ
どちらかわからない状態で
それが因縁によって生まれた
創られた 合成したものであって
そんな品の高いものじゃない
自然に生まれるんだから品の高いものでないと言うんですよ
どうせ生まれるんだから
しかし あの平安な気持ちはどうせ生まれるものじゃありません
これが自分の精進で作らなきゃいけない
だからそちらに品があるんです
落ち着いてるんだよ タッサタンウッパンナンマナータンウッパンナンアムナータンウッパンナンマナータンマナータンニルッジャティ
そういう人が心地よさが生まれても
たちまち心は平安に戻ってもらう
そこで修行できるんですよ
この自分の心と そこは自由ということなんですよ
花見て喜んじゃって それからもう一番安い酒いっぱい持ってきて
あのね ゴザを敷いてふざけて遊んじゃうと
もう花にやられただけでしょ
何のことのない すぐ三日で落ちる花が
立派な人間を馬鹿にしているんですね
なんか犬に飼われたような感じでしょうね
だからそこだからお釈迦様それは品がないと言うんですね
その瞬間で自分が平安作る
心の中で 平安作ったらもう自由ですよ
鼻にやられてないんです
鼻に自分の心を あの 何と言いますかいじられてないんです
操られてないんです タッサタンウッパンナ
ウッパンナ マナーパン ウッパンナ マナーパン ウッパンナ マナーパナ ニルッジェティ
その時は あの 一時的に現れた心地よさが
心地悪さが あるいは普通の気持ち
感情がニルッジェティ
消えてると 一回は生まれますよ
鼻をいった瞬間で なんとも気分が瞬間良くなるんだけど
すぐ次の瞬間でそれが消えちゃうんです
ウペッカニ持っていくんだから
だからこの訓練をずっとやってみると
かなりの心が成長したことになりますよ
見るたびにその訓練すると
すっごい大物になりますよ
精神的に ちょこっとしたシンプルな訓練なんです
しかし これ完璧な道なんです
他方法はありません そこで
あの瞬間に生まれた心地よさが
心地悪さが あるいは普通の気持ち
消えちゃって 平安が平安という気持ちがきちっと心に付くんだよと
セイヤター キヤーナンダ チャックマー プリソー ウッミーレットア ニンミーレイエ ニンミーレットア ウッミーレイエ
それお釈迦様たとえるんですよ
例えばアーナンダ チャックマー プリソー
目がある人はウッミーレットア ニンミーレイエ
目を開けて閉じる あるいは閉じて開ける
瞬間でしょ 我々には瞬間で目を開け
開けることもできるし
開けて閉じることはできます
閉じて開けることもできます
こんなような感じで ヤッサカ サティ エワン スィーガン
誰かにそれぐらい早く目が開けて閉じるぐらい速さで閉じて開けるぐらいの速さでエワン スィーガン エワン トゥアタン
それぐらい早くエワン アッパカシレーネーワ
そのように あの苦労なし
アッパカシラっていうのは全く苦労は 0 ということ
何て言ったら 楽 軽々く
日本の皆様方はアッパカシラという単語はあまり好きじゃないと思います
なぜならば 何やろうともまあカッタカタになるまで苦労しなくちゃ
なんか仕事をした気分にならないでしょう
大した仕事もないのに
もうずっと 3行までやった人が
それまた給料もないんですからね
あれはサービスですからね
ちょっとしたことでも
もう簡単にできるのに
もう無茶苦茶にかしたくて
もう苦労して苦労して
やった仕事をしまったと
だからそういうことは美徳にしているんだから
苦労しないっていうことはあんまりね
かっこよくないね だから仏道も本当に簡単ですけどね
あまりなんか人気ないんですね
だから時々我々は言いますけど
だったらこれ厳しいんだけどね
こういうふうにやってください
できませんしね 結局は
昨日もあの方へもうかなり知識人のように見えましたけどね
ちょこっと時間体を止めてくださいと
たった分なんですけど
分間の間ずっと体を動かす
動かしっぱなしなんです
なのに気分的にはもうすごい厳しい修行でなきゃやる気はならないという態度なんですね
だからこれって困りますけどね
この矛盾的な生き方はね
本当は苦労しないで仕事をできたならば格好いいんですよ
それが才能ということなんです
他の人には日かかる仕事なのに,自分がもう時間でやったと
他の人なら時間もかかる仕事なのに,自分は時間でやっちゃったというのは才能であって
かっこいいことであって
だからって仕事を失敗するのはもう仕事はできないんだから
それは意味がないんだけど
だからあの 苦労することが美徳じゃないんです
逆はいいんで 苦労してでも仕事を正しくやりなさいっていうのは
まとめない言い方なんですよ
苦労なんか惜しもんじゃないよと
ちゃんと仕事をしろよと
やることはちゃんとやりなさいと
仕事であろうが勉強であろうが
ガチャガチャ言うんじゃなくて
しっかりやりなさいと
こうなんかもうもう気にするもんじゃないよっていうのは正しいんだけど
あんた全然苦労していないんだから
仕事になってないんだけど
おかしいんですよ あんた作業してないでしょとかね
なんで早く家に帰るのかとかね
みんな作業しているのにとかね
その時はそれは仕事できないんだからですよと言って帰る勇気がないんですよ
まあそれはそれはそれでご苦労様で仕事できないんだからしょうがないでしょうと
私は自分の仕事終わりましたから帰りますよと
その勇気がないんでしょうしね
だからこの普通論理社会ではね
理性のある社会では 一応あの格好いいのは簡単淡然でササササと仕事終わった方がかっこいいんです
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
このあの目が開けて閉じる
閉じて開けるぐらいの労働力で
あの気持ちをカチッと入れ替えると
目で何か見たら気分良くなった
あるいは気分悪くなったとか
気持ちあるでしょ 瞬間に平安な心になると
苦労しない どれぐらい時間かかるのかというと
まぶたが閉じるぐらい時間でやってちょうだいよと
だから苦労しなさいという意味じゃないんです
それだったら まあその比丘がそのように心はまぶたが開けて閉じるぐらいの努力で
それぐらいの労働力で心を平安状態に戻す
心には波が現れ 瞬間だけ
花見た瞬間で気分が良くなるのは因果法則だから
これ避けられませんよ
花があって 目があって
見える認識が 視覚が生まれて
そこで感覚が楽しいってことになるのはセット
人間の目の場合は カラスの目の場合は別なセットかもしれませんし
それは分かりませんだからね
喋る人は聞いてみてください
私に教えてください カラスどう見えるのかと
桜の花とかね 熱海ではなんか別な種類の鳥たちもいますけど
あの連中は別になんて美しい花ではなくて食べるんです
モクレンとかなんとかというあの大きな白い花とかあるでしょうね
なんかちょっとかっこ悪い鳥たちが来てね
花のところに座ってちゃ座ってて
葉っぱ引っ張っちゃって
花びらをね 引っ張って食べるんです
食べる時も贅沢で引っ張ったものはこれをいらん
一番あの元気な艶のいいものを取って食べるんで
だからそれは鳥にはそういう風に見える
だから人間だから 我々のは花見た瞬間で
認識が生まれた瞬間で
同時に感覚として喜びっていうものが生まれる
セットですから それは同意になりませんよ
それ次の瞬間で まぶた閉じるぐらい速さで心は平安な状態に戻る
戻す これがアヤンウッチャティアーナンダ
ありやすいね アヌッサラ
インドリヤ・バハナ 仏道のとか
とく 優れた 聖なる インドリヤ・バハナがこれですと
ものすごい論理的でしょ
それから 実践不可能っていうことではないでしょう
この感情に溺れることで
人間はものすっごく苦労します
飲み屋さんなんかにね
銀座なんかに行くのはね
とにかく あのだらしない品のないあの感情の世界に溺れるためなんですよ
そこで二時間で五十万とかね
もう払って帰ってくる
お金でね こう貧しい人々でも助けちゃえばね
で 全部日本政府ばっかり任せちゃってね
政府はもうもう世界一赤字大国家で
もう無駄無駄遣いだけしか頭が機能しないんだからね
別に日本の国は赤字になるはずと私は思いませんだけどね
恐ろしい無駄ですよ だからすごく赤字
節約しないと で でも一般の人々には金がある人々もいる
いるんだったらね もっと有効に使えばいいのに
それはどうでもいい話ですから
そこはやめますけど あの
そこでちょこっとコメント注が必要なんです
ここでなんでバハナ なんで修行というのかというと
では私たちにもまぶた閉じるくらい瞬間にできますか？というと
感情入れ替えちゃったと
できないでしょ それで修行してみるんですよ
最初はもう十分かかるかもしれませんよ
花が見て舞い上がっちゃって
落ち着きましょうと 落ち着きましょうと言って
冷静になるまでには十分ぐらいかかるかもしれませんし
時々一日経っても落ち着かない人いるでしょ
興奮状態で もう花見に行って帰ってからも家の中うるさい
興奮はもう落ち着いてないというね
日二日続く人もいるし
時々一生その興奮状態持っていく人もいるし
これっていうのは全く能力ない奴隷ということなんですね
そこで仏道修行を始めた人は
まあ挑戦はするんです
できるだけ早く落ち着こうだと
クールな状態に戻るんそうと
冷静になるそうと そこで十分かかった人は五分で冷静になるとかね
それから二 三分で冷静になるようになってきて
またまた修行すると 一分以内で冷静になるようになって
さらに修行すると まあ三十秒で冷静になることができちゃって
さらに修行してみると
一秒以内でも冷静になれると
さらに修行すると 瞬間に
一番最短距離で時間的に
冷静になると これまぶた閉じる例えを出したのはそのわけなんです
ということは 目に花の映像が映った瞬間で
その瞬間で喜びが生まれるんですよ
その次の瞬間で冷静になるということなんです
これが結構瞑想進んだ人なんですよ
いわゆるこれヴィパッサナー瞑想なんですよ
こちらこの説明しているのは
このヴィパッサナー瞑想で
ヴィパッサナー瞑想がこのギリギリのところへ進んだら
ものすごくスピードアップになるんです
確認が ものすごい それはもう最速この最速のスピードで確認しなくちゃいけないんです
それで あの悟りにすぐ瞬時に飛び出すんです
悟りの境地に飛び出すためには
この今実況中継でやってるでしょ？遅い遅い
あれはもう信じられないぐらい遅い
ふくらみ ぶちちめとかね
これがこのサマーディの集中力をものすごく増してきて
もう徹底的にやってるともうすっごくスピードアップになってもうなってくるので
だからそのレベルのところでこちら結論出してます
だからまぶたの例出してるのはそういうわけで
まぶた閉じるぐらいの時間で冷静になりなさいと
まばたきの  そうそう まばたき
まばたきのぐらいの速さで冷静になりなさいと
はい それは目について
次に耳に音が触れる 音が触れたら気持ちよくなるし
心地悪くなるし あるいは両方一変になったりもするし
気分が変わる これがもうどうしようもないんです
音が聞いたら瞬時に気持ちいいか悪いかなっているんです
そちらには善悪はないんです
自然法則 音が入ったら気持ち悪くなったか
気分が良くなったか ところ
瞬間までは自然法則 しかし
気持ち良くなったこと
気持ち悪くなったことは続けちゃうと
もうドレッド それから善悪の世界になっちゃうんです
そこで耳に音が触れて
気持ち悪くなったり良くなったりした瞬間で
次の瞬間で冷静になる
あれが品がない できたもの
因縁によって生まれたもの
どうったことはない 何の価値もない
この心地よささには何の価値もない
ただ一時的 瞬間的 聞こえたんだからでしょうと
本物じゃないでしょうと
本物の気分でいい気分でいるわけじゃないでしょうに
音のおかげですからね
そこで冷静になる そこで耳で音を聞いても
まばたきと閉じるぐらいの速さで冷静になるところまで訓練に挑戦してみる
はい 次にチェックすると
Ghana 鼻がありますね
鼻に香りが入っちゃう
匂いが入っちゃう 匂いや香りが入った瞬間で気持ち悪いか気持ちいいか
もうすぐ生まれちゃう
すぐ心に波が現れて 波が現れたら
次の瞬間であ これが品がない
一時的なもの 因果法則によって現れたもの
作られたもの 出来上がったもの
だから冷静になるんだと
冷静になる 鼻の次は舌ですね
舌に何か もうどうせ食べなくちゃいけないしね
舌に何か入ったら 瞬間に気持ちよくなったり悪くなったりする
そこまで因果法則だから
もう変えることはできません
次の瞬間でこの気持ちよさが
この美味しいと感じた
この気持ちよさが大したことはない
あまり品のあることじゃない
ただの因果法則の結果
だから冷静になるんだと
それで味に対しても冷静になる
それもまばたきを閉じるぐらい速さで
それぐらいの労働力でできるように
できるようになるようにやらなくちゃいけないんです
次 カヤですね 体 体にいろんなものが触れたりするでしょうね
触れた瞬間に気持ちいいか気持ち悪いかとかね
現れますよ 現れたら まあそれはもうただの原因で気持ちよくなっただけや
それはただの原因で気持ち悪くなっただけやと
これはどうったことはない
もうあまりただの原因で生まれたものを冷静に見るぞと
で 瞬間に冷静になることを訓練する
で 六番目 心に何かアイディアが浮かんじゃうというか
何か妄想 概念がパッと入っちゃう
入った瞬間で気持ちいいか悪いかも決まってます
次の瞬間でこの気持ちよさがね
この気持ち悪さが この原因でアイディアがあって
それは思考に入ったんだから
思考したんだだから気持ちよくなったり
気持ち悪くなったり どういったことはない
ただの原因結果 品がない
それは あれこれと妄想して舞い上がって喜んだり
えー気持ち悪いと 妄想にふけって楽しむのはね
かなりやってますからね
えらい気持ち悪いんです
あれは だから次の瞬間で冷静に
それもまばたきの速さでできるように訓練してみるんです
この無数できればもう人間じゃないでしょうね
人間を乗り越えてるすっごい達人ですよ
そういう人っていうのはこの世の中で興奮すると思いますかね？何があっても
みんな興奮して失敗するでしょ
子供たちでも一生懸命勉強するのに
試験に行ったら興奮しちゃって何もできなくなっちゃう
かわいそうでしょ だから冷静にいるっていうことはね
なんで仕事が失敗するの？って興奮状態
だから火事になろうか
地震になろうが もう津波が来ようが
何が起ころうが 冷静でいればものすごい巨人ですよ
精神的には だから成長というのはそういうことなんです
すごい論理的で具体的でなものなんです
だから 他の宗教で語られている
その教義とか教義とか教義とは
仏教で言ってることって違う
仏教はすごく論理 心理学的にしっかりした
もう具体的に理解できる
手で握られるような くらいぐらい具体性がある冷静さなんです
だから その本人にとってはすっごく徹底した自信があるんです
私には冷静でいられるんだぞと
できれば興奮させて させてください
興奮してみてください
させてみてください させてみてじゃないね
興奮だけ  興奮させて で
この修行を完成している人はできませんよ
だからここで超越した道なんです
人間が超えたっていうことなんです
人間超えたっていうことは
なんか空を飛べたとかね
くだらんことじゃないんです
バカバカらしい 本当に人間を超えたっていうことなんです
人間ならもう動物と全く同じ
もうすぐもう興奮しちゃって
もう何するかわからない
あの これがヴィパッサナー瞑想の一部なんです
それで あの あの まばたきの例えは
あの目に見えるものに出したんですよ
耳で音を聞いて興奮しないで冷静になる場合は別な例えなんですよ
その場合 お釈迦様使っている例えは
この力ある男が手を伸ばして縮む
縮んで伸ばすぐらいの総動力で瞬間できるでしょ
力の悪い人だったら縮ますっと伸ばすと
これぐらいの速さで労働力で耳で音を聞いたら冷静になりくださった
それから鼻で香りを嗅ぐ時
興奮したら 出てくる例えは
ハツの葉がありますね
見たことないでしょう
じゃあ上の見てください
忍バス池に とにかく仏教は語れないので
とにかく自然で自然になってください
自然をとことん観察してください
真理はそちらにあるんですよ
この鉄筋コンクリートの中には何もないんです
ものすごい精神的にストレスかけても
みんなわかってないだけで
この宇宙の波動振動をものすごくおかしくして
かえって体に細胞に映るんでしょうね
あの木のそばにいることとは随分違うんです
だから電波みたいに この宇宙すべて電波みたいなその押しでできてるでしょうね
これであれやろ 硬い もう人工的なものを
もう自然界になかったものを
ビニール製品やらあれでこれでね
作って この箱の中に閉じ込んでいてね
ものすごい不自然で不健康なんですよ
私よりもうでっかい体を持ってるんだからという健康だと思わない方がいいんです
体ボロボロよ 私は結構健康だからね
それでも でもずっと日本にいたんだからね
なんか大変ですよ ものすごい大変です
すごいストレスかかるんです
だから精神的にはいいよ
心だったら何でも管理できるのに
肉体に来るものっていうのはどうにもならん
だからできるだけこの自然の空気に触れて
自然の植物のところで土を踏んでみて
虫をよく観察して 毎日見る葉の木であっても
葉っぱ全部よく見たりしてとかね
一緒にいた方が 何の気候もいらなくなりますけどね
まあそこは余計な話で
ハツの葉に水が落ちちゃうと瞬時に落ちる
水が入れてもなんか玉になって
なんか水銀みたいにね
光っちゃうんですね 玉になってポッと落ちるんです
全く濡れない では 明日の朝
まあここら辺の散歩にしたらありますけど
やっぱり忍ば池の方がいいんで
それぐらいの速さで それぐらいの
例えば普通の葉っぱに水がついちゃうと濡れちゃうでしょ
ハツの葉はそうじゃないんで濡れません
ポソンポソンと落ちるんです
それぐらいの労働力で
あの鼻に香りが入ったところで
匂いが入ったところで
あのちょこっと微妙に波が立ちますよ心に
香りがいいとかね 臭いとかね
次の瞬間で冷静になる
次にこの舌で味を感じた時の例え話なんですけど
あまり綺麗な例えじゃないんです
もし人のベロの先にパンがある場合は
唾液がある場合は それはとても簡単に出せますね
外へ 口に溜まった唾液を外へ出すのはどれぐらい簡単なのかと
それぐらいの速さで落ち着くようにしなさいと
ただ たとえが変わっているだけなんです
次に体に触れたもの 体に何か触れたら気持ちいいか気持ち悪いかと感じたりする
その場合はのたとえ あ
間違った一つ たとえ話を間違ったっていうのは問題ないんだけど
耳で音を聞く場合のたとえは
この指を鳴らすことなんです
力ある人はそれ読まないで言ったんだからね
バラバラにそれだけで全部同じパターンやと思っちゃって間違えたんです
力ある人は指を鳴らすぐらい感じる
それくらい時間で指鳴らすために瞬間でしょうに
それぐらい速さで音を感じなさいと
体に触れる場合は 前の言った間違ったたとえ
体に何か触れた場合は
人が手を伸ばしたり縮んだりぐらいの速さでやってくださいと
それから六番目 六番目っていうのは考え方ね
頭に何か妄想が浮かんだ途端
気持ちいいか気持ち悪いかってことになりますから
その波を瞬時に断たなくちゃいけないんです
妄想なんか持ってきてはいけないんです
もう感情ずっといっぱいありますからね
どれぐらい早く切るのかというと
この例えば昔のたとえ
例えばこの鉄板みたいなものが一日中もうもうインドっていうのはもうもうすごい平らですから
もう夏だったらすっごく熱くなるんですよ
恐ろしく それで鉄板みたいなものが外でね
ずっと日に当たっていたらあったかいでしょうに
そこに水一滴二滴ぐらい落としちゃうと
水が落とす落ちるのが遅いんだと
それより落ちた瞬間でパッと消えちゃうと
まあそれはね まあフライパンででも考えてください
フライパンを空のフライパン温めて
そこと水一滴入れてみたら
どれぐらい早く消えるのかと
それぐらい速さで簡単で心に考え方が浮かんだら
その波を切って冷静にウペッカーになってくださいと
はい そこでヴィパッサナーのこの一番上のセクションです
こちらで言っても 私たちはもう修行しなくちゃいけないんです
最初はね 何秒で何分で冷静になるのかという訓練しなきゃ意味がないんです
あれ今日から宿題ですよ
感情の奴隷で生きてるんじゃなくて
どれぐらい瞬間で感情が消して冷静になれるのかという
その訓練しないと それで確実にすごい精神的には巨人というかね
もう人間でないと言えるぐらいしっかりと成長することだけは確実に確かなんです
次のセクション セクション二番目に入ります
これセクション一ですよ
今瞑想のね  [背景音楽]